françois bayrou est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bon c'est merci d'être
avec nous c'est bien sûr le président du
modem que nous recevons mais aussi le
maire de pau nous sommes ici au congrès
des maires de france pau ville où là
vous avez organisé un festival le
week-end dernier pour célébrer le
bonheur avec avec des écrivains avec des
habitants avec moi ce soir deborah
claude de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire comme chaque semaine pour
preuve par trois avec dailymotion et
bien sûr perrine tarneaud de public
sénat françois bayrou ce n'est pas avec
nicolas sarkozy que vous pourriez je
pense célébrer le bonheur d'une relation
apaisée celui ci ne cesse de vous cibler
dans la dernière ligne droite de la
campagne pour la présidence de l'ump il
vous tient à toujours responsable de sa
défaite en 2012 et quand un militant ump
par exemple hier à angers lens dans la
salle honte à bayrou que
lâche nicolas sarkozy vous m'avez
compris vous que répondez-vous à
l'ancien chef de l'état
bon peut-être trouvera-t-il un prétexte
avec l' envie d'attaquer quelqu'un
d'autre
suivez mon regard alain juppé peut
imaginer que que c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
est donc bon je vois ça avec beaucoup de
philosophie
comme quand même le sentiment que il ya
un petit malaise du côté de nicolas
sarkozy en ce moment parce qu'ils
avaient co non peu vis-à-vis de lui-même
plus large vis-à-vis de sa propre
campagne électorale
bon faut pas aller plus loin il ya il ya
une chose qui m'a encore plus interloqué
il a dit de je serai prêt naturellement
avoir des relations apaisées mais il
faut
qu'il prenne l'engagement d'être avec
moi ma matin 10 soit midi et soir et
vous allez voter le bonheur que vous que
nous analysions ensemble à pau avec des
milliers et milliers de personnes et des
grands philosophes et alors franchement
matin nicolas sarkozy midi nicolas
sarkozy soir soir nicolas sarkozy c'est
trop
il peut arriver
que l'on est une autre idée du bonheur
et donc de ce point de vue là je ne
je ne me suis pas senti à l'envers vers
ce bonheur là non je veux dire
simplement que
je ne crois pas
que le fait de mettre une telle
intensité de détestation
dans la vie politique française qu'on a
vu à bordeaux lorsque alain jp a été
sifflé et hué
qu'on aperçoit dans dans tout ce moment
de campagne électorale je ne pense pas
que ce soit bon est-ce que ça n'est ni
pour l'ump mais c'est pas mon affaire ni
pour le pays et ça c'est davantage une
alfa la monnaie de la pièce vous n'avez
pas été tendre dans le passé avec
nicolas sarkozy lors de son quinquennat
est par ailleurs et vous voyez on
reproche toujours et ce c'est aussi le
discours des militants une trahison
de en quoi il y avait une élection et je
n'ai pas voté pour nicolas sarkozy
genève est passé vous allez voter
françois hollande est aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy vous demande en quelque
sorte mea culpa real est prêt je n'ai
pas souhaité que nicolas sarkozy soit
réélu et si je comprends bien je ne suis
pas tout seul aujourd'hui dans ce
sentiment si je comprends bien y compris
parmi ceux qui appartiennent au même
parti que lui il y en a beaucoup
qui partage aujourd'hui ce sentiment de
gêne en face de la manière dont nicolas
sarkozy conduit la politique français il
a envie de vous entendre exprimer des
regrets d'avoir fauté français alors que
vous n'y a toujours pas prêt à soirans à
bayrou il faut que vous mesuriez que où
que vous compreniez que ce genre de ce
genre de comment dirais-je de
de mise en cause là
si on
cosy il va falloir qu'ils se rendent
compte
et pas ceux tu es candidat contre lui ce
qu'il met en cause tous les soirs dans
les meetings ni moi même ni peut-être
même marine le pen ni ceux qui ne l'ont
pas soutenu avec assez de force le
premier responsable de son échec c'est
lui même c'est la manière dont nicolas
sarkozy à gouverner qui a fait que des
millions de français 4 millions qui
n'était pas de gauche
ont jugé qu'il était très important que
une alternance se produisent avec une
parfaite conscience que le parti
socialiste allait être placée au pied du
mur et que au pied du mur de la réalité
on verrait que son programme n'est pas
adapté à laisser le sol humant la
déclaration que j'avais fait mais je
vous aviez vous je vous le répète je
veux pas de résultats par exemple
économique vous l'aviez anticiper cela
je l'avais non seulement anticipé mais
dit il suffit que vous repreniez les les
enregistrements de deux séjours
l'anglais bien voter contre nicolas
sarkozy et pas cher pour une alternance
en espérant que hélas mon espoir n'a pas
été couronné de succès en espérant que
françois hollande se rendrait compte
assez tôt des dégâts que ces positions
risquées faisait courir aux pays
d'accueil notamment se connaît tous et
non pas vers vous au début de son
quinquennat du tout je je je ne me mets
pas dans ce paysage là mais les
engagements le programme économique la
manière dont il envisageait l'économie
du pays me paraissait alors très
aventureux réussirez pas vous devriez
avoir une explication franche avec
nicolas sarkozy dans les semaines qui
viennent vous seriez peut vous seriez
prêt mais moi j'ai toujours parlé avec
tout le monde j'ai parlé avec lui on
plus forts de notre part de mandalas
j'ai parlé avec françois hollande quand
françois hollande
quand alors même que j'étais en
désaccord avec un oasis de mais moi je
suis je devrais je ne suis pas quelqu'un
de sectaire voyait mêmes je considère
que le séisme lui oui non
michel grossiord n'essayez pas de me
faire dire ce que j'ai pas envie de dire
vous n'y arriverez pas ça nous fait
perdre du temps et c'est donc inutile
donc je je choisis exact incubés ok mais
formule pas justement au caire et donc
je suis l'ennemi du sectarisme alors je
pense que le sectarisme est un virus
épouvantables dans un pays en crise dans
la démocratie en général oui dans un
pays en crise en particulier et vous
voyez bien tout ce qui est en train de
se produire tout à l'heure c'était
intéressant pendant les discours au
congrès des maires il y a eu
des affirmations du président sortant
monsieur pélissard qui a dit quelque
chose que je partage absolument il s'en
est pris à tous ceux qui aujourd'hui
dans la politique français se baladent
en disant on va tout abrogée on a
compris fo suivez mon regard des
symphonies l'abrogation la loi taubira
qui fort non non
plusieurs abrogation qui font de
l'abrogation
l'alpha et l'oméga le commencement et la
fin de la politique c'est pour moi un
gâchis jacques pélissard le président
sortant de l'association des maires de
france a défendu justement la continuité
républicaine en est exactement la
prochaine abrogation de certains textes
votés sous la gorge vous considéré comme
étant d'une rupture je pense que le
mouvement de balancier camp contre camp
clan contre klan qui résume la vie
politique française depuis des décennies
nous a conduits où nous sommes c'est un
mouvement qui favorise les paresseux
parce que qu'est ce qu'a fait le parti
socialiste dans l'opposition pendant
cinq ans rien qu attendre que le
balancier re traversent la frontière et
on nous avait raconté souvenez-vous que
il y avait des commissions qui avaient
travaillé
fantastiquement pour savoir ce qu'on
allait faire jour par jour les cent
premiers jours en réalité tout ça
c'était évidemment du bluff elle ça
n'existait pas comme et donc je souhaite
moi que le le principe de la politique
française
abandonne
cette fatalité du balancier qui fait que
ceux qui arrivent annuler ce qu'ont fait
les précédents et que les précédents
n'ont qu'une envie c'est d'annuler ce
que feront les suivants parce que ça
nous a conduit à des catastrophes et je
souhaite qu'on essaie de réfléchir à la
manière dont on peut dans notre pays
construire un progrès continu ce qui
veut dire qu'il va falloir changer la
pratique politique du pays alors pour
l'instant nicolas sarkozy envisage de
construire une alternance ump élargi au
centre mais sans vous est ce que vous
êtes et peiné par
cette exclusion mais je crois qu'en ce
qu'on se rend pas compte il ya eu un
temps où ce genre d'affirmation pouvait
avoir crédibilité mais lorsque vous avez
une extrême droite au-dessus de 25% et
que le parti en question celui de
nicolas sarkozy et nicolas sarkozy lui
même étoffe n'arrive pas à ce niveau là
mais le l'idée qu'on fait des occases
qu'on fait siffler les gens qu'on fait
huer les autres cancon qu'on me dit
qu'on qu'on veut exclure cette idée là
elle montre seulement qu'on n'a pas les
yeux en face des trous qu'on voit pas la
réalité comme elle est et qui va falloir
d'une certaine manière évoluer parce que
je prédis autrement de des moments
difficiles en on verra cela après ce
week-end après l'élection du président
de l'ump en tout état de cause après
nicolas sarkozy qui devrait l'emporter
est-ce que vous pensez que je le suivrai
électeurs dans cette élection et encore
moins sondeurs et si vous aviez à voter
ce serait beau mais je suis aucune
chance que j'ai à voter d'accord évident
mais en tout état de cause on peut se
dire que celui qui sortira vainqueur du
scrutin interne à l'ump sera demain le
candidat en 2017 mans à l'heureuse ça
c'est ce que nicolas sarkozy pense et
voudrait mais vous savez bien qu'il y
ait un débat très important autour de ce
qu'on appelle les primaires vous verrez
pouvait primaire et quelle est la forme
des primaires et qui participe aux
primaires
c'est pas un secret que je vais vous
confier moi je ne suis pas très emballé
par les primaires par le prince à vous
faire un point de divergence avec alain
juppé oui mais nous nous en serions
votre providentiel ne nous en sommes
j'ai expliqué on parlera de ça vous
voulez bien laissez-moi aller jusqu'au
bout de l'idée de primaires et de et de
mes interrogations en face de cette idée
les primaires ça signifie qu'on organise
une consultation dans un camp
et que donc il n'y a que deux camps dans
la politique française est pour moi si
vous ne donnait que deux camps dans la
politique française il me semble que
vous favorisez beaucoup les votes qu'on
appelle protestataires extrémistes et le
front national en particulier que ce qui
a fait la fortune
de marine le pen
c'est d'ailleurs son thème à peu près
unique c'est l'ump
scc le fait qu'il n'y avait que deux ont
dit à peu la même chose vous dites l'ump
et le ps sont morts un
oui mais ça ce n'est pas la même chose
mais c'est je vous voyez bien que c'est
à peu près exactement le contraire ce
que je pense moi qui est très très clair
c'est que
il y a d'autres propositions à faire aux
pays d'autres voies à suivre que celle
qui se succédant depuis des années nous
ont conduits à l'endroit où cela ce sera
ma taux d'élèves ses rayons c'est le
pire donc de 2,7 à lucien que le pays.la
défendent c'est vous qui l'incarné qu'il
incarnerait une quatrième fois lors de
l'élection présidentielle françois
bayrou aussi par exemple alain juppé que
vous soutenez n'est pas vainqueur de la
primaire ouverte oui ou non est ce que
vous avez interrogé sur alain juppé je
vous dire des choses très simples et sur
20 je pense qu'il a un bon profil
d'expérience de vision des choses pour
rendre service au pays et je suis prêt à
l'y aider il n'y a pas beaucoup de
deux responsables politiques qui
s'affirme ainsi de manière désintéressée
près en aider d'autres à la séculaire et
donc s'ils échouent s'il échoue s'il
échoue je suis un homme libre et vous
repartez reçu un homme libre a
aujourd'hui repartir sur un homme libre
a aussi pour repartir sur le 4e tour je
vais vous dire autre chose non je suis
et je serai un homme libre le matin le
midi et le soir voilà le jour de
l'essentiel aujourd'hui tour de la
prochaine présidentielle
c'est ça non non je vous dit pas non si
j'avais su ça vous si j'avais cela vous
dire monsieur grosseur je vous le dirai
c'est trop tôt c'est donc c'est je suis
absolument pas dans ce genre de calcul
de manners fera bien aller 2010 est donc
je ne pense qu'à enfin je ne pense je
suis habité par deux sentiments le
premier c'est l'inquiétude devant la
situation du pays on va en parler le
deuxième c'est qu'on peut faire quelque
chose la plupart des gens croient que
c'est foutu la plupart des gens croient
que au fond baissent les bras et puis ce
10 mai on n'y peut rien c'est toujours
pareil et moi je crois exactement le
contraire je pense qu'on peut faire des
choses déterminantes pour que ce pays
fatigué et parfois désespérés retrouve
l'énergie vitale dont il a besoin et un
peu d'allégresse on en est tous
convaincus avec vous sur ce point là un
françois bayrou mais 2017 est dans
toutes les têtes à gauche aussi où l'on
parle également de primaire vous l'avez
entendu y compris pour françois hollande
d'ailleurs face à un pouvoir en
difficulté sans résultat on le disait il
ya un instant mais comment réagissent
donc les maires socialistes qui sont
présents ici ce congrès qui se déroule
autour de nous le reportage ce matin
dans les allées du salon de marie
dremeaux avant d'accueillir deborah
claude de l' agence france-presse
pas évident pour les mères d'afficher
leur étiquette politique quand on est
socialiste à l'heure où leurs familles
affronte de nombreuses tempêtes et de
plus en plus de mécontentement
il est certain que les choix nationaux
sont faits ne sont pas passés là assumée
il ya il est vrai une certaine
inquiétude par rapport notamment aux
dotations de l'état par rapport à un
certain nombre de normes qui sont
demandés donc c'est une des inquiétudes
qui est important que chaque maire a
aujourd'hui à l'esprit les maires
socialistes doivent en effet assumer des
réformes politiques difficiles baisse
des dotations carte territoriale rythme
scolaire
mais contrairement à la morosité
ambiante
pas question pour eux de quitter le
navire à l'heure où taper sur le pouvoir
exécutif est devenu un sport national
ma famille ne va pas très bien mais je
vais pas en changer à mon âge je veux
pas me réfugier en disant moi les locaux
c'est ce sont les responsables nationaux
qui me font
au fond la misère entre guillemets petit
et localement il faut qu'on prenne tous
à tous les espions des fans autre part
de responsables de prendre leur part de
responsabilité dans une france en pleine
crise politique économique et sociale
même si cela veut dire il le service
bien assumé de probable défaite aux
cantonales et aux régionales en 2015 moi
je sais que j'ai proposé avec des amis
de faire campagne sur le thème ne jetez
pas le bébé avec l'eau du bain et ça
veut dire quoi se dire que vous êtes
vous avez des mécontentements est ce que
c'est une raison pour vous priver élus
sur lequel vous pensez qu'ils font bien
leur boulot pour ne pas mettre tous les
hommes politiques dans le même panier
voilà le message des maires socialistes
aux français celui adressé à la classe
politique nationale est tout autre je
pense qu'il ya
c'est r entre eux il ya une vraie
certains v10 entre la france diot et la
france du bas âge faut pas reprendre ses
termes mais il ya une vraie adéquation
une adéquation entre ce qui est décidé
au niveau des gouvernements et ce qu'ils
aient décidées localement
voilà donc de fortes attentes et puis de
l'amertume on l'a entendu également chez
les élus socialistes françois bayrou
c'est déborah clos deux de l'agencé
france presse qui nous a rejoint le soir
d'abord à vos questions président du
modem vous qu est par ailleurs une
spécialiste du centre là on va parler un
petit peu la honte vient d'enjoindre les
maires socialistes le gouvernement
socialiste par ailleurs demande beaucoup
d'efforts aux collectivités locales vous
est-ce que vous approuvez ces efforts et
ces coupes budgétaires qu'on demande aux
mairies aux départements et aux régions
écoutez moi je ne cherche enfin je
cherche une chose dans un engagement
politique c'est un peu de cohérence
il se trouve qu'il y a quinze ans
que j'ai
multiplié les analyses et les
avertissements et les propositions pour
qu'on mesure que le l'abandon à la dette
et aux déficits
était une manière de
dérives dont nous ne reviendrions pas
aisément et qu'on allait connaître de
terribles lendemains qui déchantent en
se laissant aller à cela alors cette
façon d'approuver alors les économies
alors alors l'idée que aujourd'hui
simplement parce que je suis devenu
maire de de pauw
j'ai été président du conseil général
autrefois
l'idée que parce que j'occupe cette
fonction je me mettrai à plaider le
contraire de ce que je disais hier cette
idée excusez moi de vous le dire elle ne
me ressemble pas ou alors est-ce que
allégresse que est-ce que j'approuve le
détail des cheveux mais l'acte général
qui est que on va devoir en effet entrer
dans une démarche de dépenses publiques
maîtriser
c'est un premier axe que je considère
comme incontournable quels que soient
les gouvernements celui ci les suivants
ou d'autres après il n'y aura pas
d'autre voie possible c'est que la
première manche mais à la différence de
beaucoup
je vais vous le dire peut-être ça me
vaudra des critiques je ne vois pas cela
comme une punition je ne vois pas cela
comme un chemin de croix je vois cela
comme si nous le prenons en main si nous
avons suffisamment de
d'imagination de capacité de créativité
je pense que ce peut être une chance
d'aller vers des réorganisations
nécessaires vous êtes peu nombreux à
dire ce qu'elle a pensé au congrès des
maires de france ont l'argent je suis de
gauche à droite et même discours je suis
peut-être parle de brutalités et je
comprends très bien les difficultés je
les vis comme maire et comme présidente
d'agglomération cependant si nous avons
cette volonté chevillée au corps nous
pouvons faire de cette contrainte de
cette obligation je le crois une chance
de ré pour réinventer l'action publique
encore faut-il que nous ayons les mains
libres et l'imagination nécessaire pas
quoi et donc dans les accords pour créer
des impôts
monsieur les impôts je n'en avais pas
gelé baisse alors je j'ai baissé les
impôts en 2014 et gelé baisserait en
2015 parce que je considère qu'on est
trop imposer et que donc le pour moi en
tout cas saisir cette nécessité pour en
faire une obligation c'est important en
revanche il ya quelque chose qui a été
dit par un des maires socialistes qui se
sont exprimés et que je crois juste il
dit mais on peut pas faire ça en étant
écrasés sous les normes sous les
contraintes sous les règles qu'on nous
impose et qui ne comprennent pas le b à
ba de la réalité jamais autant parlé de
simplification oui mais messieurs aux
mondiaux on parle de certification fait
rien mais vous comprenez ça c'est vous
voyez c'est parce que je foutais je vois
quand tu demandes on simplifie je vous
raconte une histoire très simple et vrai
et qui date d'il ya quelques jours vous
savez qu'un jour sur un plateau de
télévision j'ai montré le code du
travail
j'ai comparé et beaucoup d'amis comme un
bottin quittant les poids respectifs
du code du travail suisse et du code du
travail français
1500 pages ou quelque chose de cet ordre
l'éditeur du code est venu me voir il
m'a dit j'ai vu que vous aviez que vous
aviez la version 2012 alors je vous
apporte la version 2014 elle fait 500
pages de plus c'est la joue et il m'a
dit on est autant en septembre mais il
m'a dit donc c'est pas la jurisprudence
ne ne tombait pas ou ne soyez pas qu on
attachait pas du crédit à ces bobards je
vous montrerai
quand vous viendrez dans mon bureau la
prochaine fois le texte sans commentaire
aucun mais là aussi il peut être la
volonté du département oui je n'ai pas
fini mais je veux finir en une phrase
votre histoire et il me dit le code là
que je vous apporte ce qui pèse 2 kg
dont il est sorti en mars
depuis le mois de mars 10% des articles
ont changé en étant septembre ils ont
été obligés d'inventer un outil
informatique pour que avec son
smartphone on puissent photographier de
la page et que par reconnaissance de
texte on vous donne le nouveau texte ça
c'est la france et c'est la france du
droit du travail mais c'est la france de
tous les droits que tous les ai pas la
honte à afin d'apprendre ministre
d'économie apparemment un mouvement
continu qui veut
un petit peu accéléré libérer la
croissance avec avec ses projets mais
simplement est ce que ça vous en avait
parlé que manuel valls quand vous l'avez
vu apo / le les finances le parquet ils
vivent avec manuel valls est souvent
avec françois hollande est souvent
auparavant avec nicolas sarkozy et
souvent avec les premiers ministres avec
avec françois fillon et avec les
précédents aussi parce que je vous
rappelle il ya quinze ans depuis l'année
1999 ou 2000 que j'ai fait de ce combat
de 2,2 de cette bataille une bataille
fondatrice pour la france elle vous ai
dit on avait fait au début des années
2000 le choix qu'il fallait la france
dans serait pas là aujourd'hui les choix
qu'il fallait la france n'en serait pas
là aujourd'hui elle valls ne manque pas
de courage donc vous apporter un certain
crédit c'est vrai aux axes qui peut
prendre quelle son accent principal
qu'il prend c'est de dire que le parti
socialiste comme il est c'est fini il
propose mal dit que de nom et donc je
trouve que quand on est à la tête d'une
majorité d'un parti ça ne manque pas de
courage que de dire cela est-ce qui va
être suivi par son parti j'en doute un
peu commération mois de journée mais
l'agent maintenant un peu la réforme
maintenant est ce que ce sont des choses
qui peuvent vous jeudi le sait pas ce
qu'il y a dans la loi va nous n'avons
pas venir mais moi alors on fait des
commentaires ont fait des gloses autour
d'un texte qu'on ne connaît pas
j'attendrai de connaître le texte sur
les 35 heures c'est aussi un chantier
qui a été ouvert par bercy vous
approuvez là également la volonté il a
espéré monsieur crusher du travail
disons des choses précises non seulement
le chantier n'a pas été ouvert mais il y
a eu une communication officielle du
gouvernement pour dire ce chantier ne
sera jamais rouvert fin du régime du rpt
et les galons cachez ce sein que je ne
saurais voir comme dit
tartuffe et donc le bon c'est là qu'on
en est alors j'attendrai de voir mais si
vous me demandez mon avis à moi je pense
que le temps de deux travail est une des
seules variables un des seuls éléments
que nous pouvons saisir pour rendre
notre pays plus vivant qu'il y ait
davantage de vide à libérer la durée
mais il ya aussi une autre proposition
de deux économistes français et
allemands qui va encore plus loin que la
flexibilité sur des bras le chaleur pas
précisément non plus le contenu de ce
rapport parce que ça a été publié par un
journal par une fuite et non non je
n'essaie pas le cheveu non je vous dis
tout cas je vais vous dire ce que je
peux que les sectes lequel et ce à
l'heure chez lui contre le blocage des
salaires autant je suis pour qu'on
travaille sur le temps de travail pour
permettre aux gens de de s'investir
autant je suis opposé à l'idée qu'on va
verrouiller dans un corset le l'ensemble
de la société du travail en france et de
l'entreprise je trouve que c'est stupide
contre productif et alors pour le coup
récessif parce que ça veut dire que le
la plupart des gens vont avoir le
sentiment que ça y est on dévale la
pente et je ne suis pas de cet avis je
pense que on peut au contraire
trouver des moyens tiens pour une fois
je vous dire que je suis en accord avec
nicolas sarkozy train vous voyez que
que cette émission et de sa maquette
jean pierre blanche en attendant on
attendre je pense que sur les heures sup
c'était lui qui avait raison
de moi j'étais pas aller aussi loin que
lui dans des visualiser les refus moi
j'étais pour décharger au moins à
concurrence des heures normales mais je
pense qu'ils avaient raison d'en faire
un élément comment dirais-je
d'engagement d'après pour pour le
travail en france déborah alors revenons
sur l'on parlait de manuel valls qui
manquent pas de courage en même temps
vous avez dit à de nombreuses reprises
que françois hollande n'allait pas tenir
jusqu'à la fin de son quinquennat là les
écologistes à l'assemblée tout à l'heure
vous votez contre la réforme
territoriale ça vous conforte dans
l'idée que la majorité n'existe plus
avec quelles solutions
ça n'est pas que la majorité de n'existe
plus et que cette réforme est une ânerie
est une duperie
les deux allaient voter elle évoque les
deux allaient voter est alors allé voter
d'abord en deuxième lecture non et puis
ensuite excusez moi de vous dire il
arrive que les majorités vote des abris
et des duperies c'est arrivé souvent là
le la la nouvelle structure des régions
alors pas pour toutes j'aperçois des
élus normands autour de nous vend la
normandie c'est bien mais faire une
seule région de l'aquitaine de poitou
charentes et du limousin avec un
périmètre qui fera 1300 ou 1400 km je
trouve que c'est privé la région de
l'essentiel c'est à dire de son âme de
son identité une région c'est
des gens qui se reconnaissent un destin
commun si vous mélangez des populations
qui n'ont ni la même culture ni la même
histoire ni la même façon de voir les
choses vous rendez un mauvais service à
la décentralisation parce que vous
enlevez l'unité qui doit être celle
d'une région pour décider de son avenir
et je le dis d'autant plus que en
aquitaine si on prend les responsables
politiques principaux
alain juppé était contre alain rousset
était contre et j'étais contre non mais
la question c'est reporter corps de cire
cette réforme donc vous avez toujours
dit elle n'ira pas jusqu'au bout c'est
très fin
j'espère que la sagesse un jour ou
l'autre feront en sorte que cette cette
duperie stupide
cedral pas devant la réalité mais alors
là vous êtes jours l'abrogation alors
non mais les pattes on n'est pas en
place non mais ça va prendre du temps
elle n'est pas en place
je vous affirme que quand vous enlevez à
une région son identité et que vous la
rendez complètement e
démesurée et et comment dirais-je est
hétérogène à l'intérieur ça ne coûtera
pas moins cher ça coûtera plus cher
d'accord il doit alors c'est pas ça je
dis que c'est nuisible accord nuisibles
en plus alors c'était la question à
laquelle je n'ai pas répondu sur la
petite île afin de gagner d'abord vous
pensez toujours que je paie pour tirer
en sortir je mets dans une liste dans un
pays en crise est une une majorité aussi
désavoué par le peuple par l'opinion
publique ne peut pas affronter les
vagues inéluctable alors quand viendront
les vagues je n'en sais rien mais je
pense que elle n'est cette majorité là
n'est pas en mesure de rendre service au
pays dans les deux années et demander
quelque chose vous vous dites vous on
sait que l'analyse je vous dis je vous
vois demandez pas de dissolution
des mises là alors pour le coup ça ne
servirait strictement à rien mais moi je
me dis que cette affaire-là est mal
barrés comme on dit mal barré mal engagé
c'est une majorité qui n'a aucune
capacité d'action sur le pays parce que
plus personne ne les écoute et vous avez
entendu les pauvres maire ps qui
s'exprimait sur les entendent alors été
abasourdi désespéré voilà merci merci
beaucoup deborah perrine tarneaud va
arriver maintenant vous avez parlé
d'autres régions françois bayrou en
valais dans votre ville d'abord pau
sébastien bourgeois est allé voir
comment et bien vous avez pris en main
les destinées de cette magnifique ville
installation de caméras de surveillance
lancement d'un salon du livre
recouvrement des taxes du centre ville
sans compter les gros dossiers comme la
réfection des halles le réaménagement
des transports urbains ou la
construction d'un auditorium 2200 places
le tout en baissant les impôts à pau
françois bayrou veut aller vite et sur
tous les fronts mais surtout qui veut
que ça se voit alors c'est marc françois
bayrou qui correspond je pense à un
grand sens de communication et pour a
besoin de sa peau a besoin de se faire
un peu connaître faire parler de lui un
maire leader national un plus pour la
ville mais aussi un style
d'administration assez particulier il
n'y a pas grand monde qui à part lui
dessine moi je pense qu'ils sont un
petit noyau de personnes décidées et ça
n'engage que moi mais même les mêmes les
adjoints je pense ne sont pas forcément
associé à toutes les prises de décision
c'est un petit comité c'est le bayrou
patron on l'a vu dès les premiers
conseils municipaux et a pas un membre
de la majorité qui moufte est parfois un
peu trop qui ne donne pas mal c'est
qu'il va regarder mais comme l'elysée
alain juppé parfois il peut être un peu
trop yo soy il devrait être un peu plus
nosotros voilà un peu plus collectif
parfois mais bon après c'est quelqu'un
c'était pour reprendre les termes
d'alain juppé mais après c'est quelqu'un
qui s'investit à fond dans un dossier
qui a je pense une bonne vision
aujourd'hui pour ce qu'il veut faire de
la vie aujourd'hui et demain pour
l'instant la majorité tient les plus
gros projets annoncés par le maire reste
à réaliser tout comme sa promesse de
baisser les impôts en maintenant
l'investissement une baisse des impôts
de 0 2% est d'ores et déjà acté la plus
grosse incertitude reste le destin
national du maire une journée par
semaine à paris un studio de télévision
à pau et depuis quelques jours une ligne
directe avec les radios nationales
permettent à françois bayrou d'être à la
fois maire de pau et président du modem
mais combien de temps cela pourra-t-il
durée l'élection de françois bayrou
c'est l'élection présidentielle c'est
son truc voilà il y retournera à coup
sûr
l'alliage qui a permis
à françois bayrou de remporter peau peut
se fissurer à partir du moment où comme
on le sait tous il prendra un peu les
distances avec pau et cette mairie pour
aller de nouveau vers le combat
présidentiel
voilà donc on découvre que pau et si
près de paris avec les moyens moteurs
communication de la mairie abbas a fait
pour ça oui bien sûr il faut faciliter
le travail donc tout ne sera pas noyé
dans sa mairie juste un mot
c'est une accusation mais elle est
fondée oui mon boulot c'est d'être le
patron de la ville bon voilà et j'assume
cette nécessité non non c'est en rien
simplement c'est vrai je tranche je
décide on réalise et il faut que ça
aille vite parce que une partie de la du
découragement des citoyens c'est que le
monde politique pro faire des promesses
et les réalisations sont complètement
absentes reporter toujours aux calendes
grecques ton pas vous experts du bureau
politique un pare brise de la salle mais
si justement excusez moi dans ce cas là
il faut que vous enregistriez dans ce
cas là précisément chez nous on décide
et ont fait et les choses se font sans
avoir à attendre les que passent les
mois et les années paires any d'avray la
mairie comme tremplin finalement
peut-être pour d'autres échéances
nationales et le précédent juppé alain
jeune et je n'ai jamais eu besoin de
tremplin je ne pratique pas le
trampoline c'est pas du tout mon sport
je suis pleinement à ma responsabilité
de maire simplement je suis un citoyen
qui voit son pays se défaire et je
n'abdique pas ma responsabilité mais je
le fais depuis
ou en habitant pleinement la
responsabilité locale qui est la mienne
c'est simple et on a maintenant comme ça
a été montrée justement on a maintenant
tous les moyens une communication des
changes qui permettent de montrer que à
800 km de paris c'est quand même là
frankel chanson à de vous avoir là en
chair et en os est
peut-être passé michel lord qu'est-ce
que vous renouvelez votre promesse que
vous avez fait pendant la campagne des
municipales de ne pas bouger de pau à
madame j'ai promis une chose précise
sais que je ne serai pas candidat aux
législatives aux sénatoriales où conseil
général vous vous êtes arrêté à mal de
nos départementales
régionales de
2014 2015 j'ai dit que je ne serai pas
député européen et ce sont des promesses
que je respect 2016 et 2017
non mais vous nous faites par le musée
non je ne fais pas de promesses que je
suis pas dans l'habileté
c'est à l'esquivé non c'est très simple
je n'abdique pas ma responsabilité de
citoyen national voilà en rien je ne je
ne je ne démissionne pas de ses
responsabilités
pour dire non désormais seul l'horizon
le calme intéresse c'est pas vrai
l'horizon local me passionne mais et on
fait des choses fantastiques mais
l'horizon nationale est pour chacun
d'entre nous un devoir donc d'engagement
pas pas simplement une option
chacun des élus qui sont présents dans
ce salon des maires est préoccupé par le
destin du pays parce que c'est du destin
du pays que dépend le destin de sa
propre communauté
alors cela j'ai envie de vous dire on
vous reçoit cinq sur cinq alors
que là là honnêtement les moyens de
communication entre nous sont assez
spontané direct à la france à bayrou
quand même sur la politique nationale le
nouveau patron dudit jean christophe
lagarde a émis le voeu de vous
rencontrer est ce que vous vous êtes
vous déjà non c'est pas vu parce que il
est un peu occupé à mettre en place son
organisation mais très prochainement ya
aucun doute est ce vous savez il aide
nous avons étés c'était une élection un
peu
familial parce que ça me yann jean
christophe lagarde femme idéale mais bon
adressé fraticide directement chercher
le mondial assez solide
amitiés dans les familles comme vous
savez politiques en particulier mais
jean christophe lagarde a été président
des jeunes sous ma responsabilité
hervé morin a été président du groupe
sous ma responsabilité
parle dans ce sens vos poulains et donc
ce ce sont des gens que je connais très
bien et avec qui j'ai partagé des
engagements importants et j'ai
l'intention de continuer parce que pour
moi il n'ya qu'une loi si le centre qui
est un devoir d'existence veut remplir
ce devoir d'existence il faut qu'ils
soient unis c'est simple comme bonjour
alors quelques questions d'actualité
françois bayrou aujourd'hui notamment le
discours du pape devant le parlement
européen réuni aujourd'hui à strasbourg
est-ce que vous adoptez le point de vue
de jean luc mélenchon pour qui le
religieux n'a pas sa place dans cette
enceinte parlementaire non je suis un
l'aï que je suis un croyant
et pratiquant
est cependant je suis très attaché à la
laïcité hélas ce n'est pas une entorse
lecture
du serment dans une enceinte politique
mais si le dalaï lama via est reçu par
le pas
insupportable et à plus forte raison
quand il s'agit du chef spirituel d'une
de la plus importante des religions
européenne profondément mêlé à son
histoire et qui a tout à fait le comment
dirais-je le la place devant une
assemblée parlementaire qui représente
les peuples pour s'exprimer devant telle
hypocrisie finalement de la part des
députés européens à applaudir le pape
quand il parle de valeur de valeurs
humaines de lutte contre
l'ultralibéralisme
d'accueil des migrants clandestins et
puis le lendemain ils vont voter pts à
des mesures qui vont à l'encontre de ce
que prône le pape devant eux et qu'ils
applaudissent ans alors il n'ya pas
d'hypocrisie nuance
pour aller au bout de la phrase
précédente c'est que pour moi
le pape est d'abord un chef spirituel et
c'est comme ça que je le regarde c'est à
dire qui
a une responsabilité devant la
conviction profonde la fois de centaines
de millions de personnes sur le
continent européen il dit un certain
nombre de choses sur l'évolution des
sociétés pour la plupart de ces
affirmations
non seulement je les partage mais je les
reçois avec gratitude je trouve que la
sensibilité de du pape françois de ce
nouveau pape elle est alors là je
m'exprime à titre personnel et comme
croyants elle est bienvenue mais surtout
quand il parle de l'évolution de
l'église non mais quand il dit que nous
avons une responsabilité devant les
migrants et que c'est pas possible que
la méditerranée devienne un cimetière et
que ce que nous faisons lampes et 12 ha
est une horreur nous les européens
puisque on laisse les pauvres italien
tout seul devant cette responsabilité là
nous sommes me nous sommes des
missionnaires et nous trahissons notre
idéal et quand le pape vient et vivent
ou europe vous avez une responsabilité
parce que vous êtes la matrice d'un
certain nombre d'évolutions du monde 2
et de la société et vous devez retrouver
la vitalité qui est celle de vos valeurs
de votre vision du monde
il a absolument raison
autre sujet d'actualité on pensait qu'il
allait se faire discret mais non thomas
thévenoud annonces plus ou moins son
retour il est de plus en plus présent
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
êtes de ceux qui pensent que les élus
qui s'avère finalement des fraudeurs
fiscaux devraient être punis
d'inégibilité
ils vont
si la fraude est confirmée je pense
qu'elle va l'être ils le seront il ya il
ya une incompatibilité entre
l'incivisme qui fait qu' on triche avec
les impôts pire qu'on déclare pas ses
impôts enfin je ne sais pas ce qui est
le pire l'un ou l'autre il ya une
incompatibilité entre cet incivisme là
et l'exercice de la responsabilité de
représentants du peuple est ce que le
bilan de la haute autorité pour la
transparence un an après son
installation est positif selon vous
forte je retrouvais la transparence java
sont résidents demain et je vais faire
le bilan avec lui vous vous souviendrez
peut-être que j'avais proposé un texte
exigeant
sur la transparence de la vie publique
avec une pétition qui avait réuni plus
de 60 mille signatures et qui disait un
certain nombre de choses très exigeante
de ce point de vue là j'en parlerai
demain avec jean louis nadal dernière
question pérenne allez on va finir
peut-être par la tournée londonienne de
notre nouvelle star de l'édition est ce
que vous êtes choqués par le holland
bashing de valérie trierweiler
je vais vous dire j'ai lu son livre
je suis pas comme ceux qui disent que
bon je les lui ai je les trouvais
infiniment triste
tellement triste triste pour elle triste
pour lui triste pour leur histoire
triste pour la fonction présidentielle
lectrice les jours ni pour la france
avec nos langages income duos et pas
seulement lente bachique jeu les
articles de journaux britanniques sont
assez cruel les y compris pour elle et
donc non je je je trouve que c'est pas
enfin c'est pas ce dont
on rêve a day s'est passé dans temps je
ne veux pas porter les porter de
jugement je veux pas employer des mots
condescendant je trouve ça triste voilà
mais vous l'avez lu vous l'avez dévorer
jusqu'au bout un dévorer pas exactement
le mot je les lui
dévorer dirrig gourmandise michel non
personnellement non merci vous êtes
arrêté quoi l'autre en courant court
encore et ça suffit d aller les secrets
d'alcôve un moment on dit stop oui oui
merci non il ya
il ya là quelque chose qui portent assez
profondément atteinte à l'idée qu'on se
fait au fond d'eux d'un moment réussi de
vie merci françois bayrou d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui au congrès des
maires de france merci perrine bonsoir a
très vite